[Music]
so
rap asked him
hey man did you have anything to
celebrate for today
he said no he's like be honest in our
profession you know honestly goes a long
way he said i'm gonna be honest i had
three benefits
i was like okay when do you have that
he's about two hours ago like why would
you take three benadryl knowing you had
to go into work tonight
he said i was just trying to sleep i
said oh you're so you're trying to
miss your shift because of that and he
said no
well i talked to a sergeant he's on his
way or he said he's probably gonna be on
his way
okay and then rap asked him to do fses
and he said no
maybe every or three months
do it
i have teachers every like two or three
months
are you on medication
what do you think
does your medication stay not to drink
and take it
does it say not to mix it with alcohol
yeah was the last time you took your
medicine
um
four days ago oh so you were thinking of
recently
okay
so do you not want to go down the
hospital right now oh no sir
he doesn't want to go to the hospital
he's refusing medical and he refused
that yeah he had he had his uniform on
he's refused fse's and
now overnight slapped his laptops
all on the floorboard
looks like it has car inside of the
display his laptop's on the floorboard
and everything
we're on south right now we're at 546
south right now
he lives off of uh
the thing is is he said that he was he's
going in 441 in park city but he's told
robert that he's on his way to work yeah
all right he said he was on his way to
work but i don't think he's not going to
work if he's on his way to work then
he's in deep trouble
because
oh he told all right well he said that
he never went into the radio get him off
the popular has no clue that he's out
here that's what he told brown
okay yeah we took these weapons and
stuff off of them already do you need to
do anything else here they didn't
believe so unless because i'm the one
that pulled them over found them first
okay
um whatever we do from this i need you
to write a supplement to it um but
go start shaving calls with 50 wraps
okay i'll write a supplement to whatever